[Música]
[Aplausos]
tuve la fortuna de tener un padre
maravilloso que me dejó dos herencias
increíbles y no precisamente dinero dos
muy importantes que me han acompañado a
lo largo mi vida tengo 43 años una de
ellas es que no tengo un solo recuerdo
negativo mi padre uno solo y el otro la
pasión por el deporte el deporte me ha
llevado a lugares inimaginables
tuve la fortuna de poder estar en
eventos internacionales les preparé un
vídeo que les quiero compartir de dos
minutos para que conozcan un poco de mi
esencia vamos a ver
[Música]
siempre pensé que estar un paso adelante
me daría la oportunidad de cumplir mis
sueños
son los momentos de esperar el día
adecuado para que ese destello pueda
abrir tu mente y materializar esa gran
idea algún día pensé viajar por el mundo
y poder transmitir con mi voz lo que mis
ojos veían ser el canal para aquellos
que no podían estar allí gracias para
para poder darme esa gran pasión por el
deporte por enseñarme que cuando amas
algo no tienes que proteger y cuidar
hasta que lo culmine es dichoso de nacer
en méjico el sentido de pertenencia por
lo que la historia nos formó eso nos
hace únicos historias que te hacen ver
tu infancia reflejada en una cancha o en
una pista es ahí cuando encuentras que
el sentido de la vida es vivirla al
máximo todos los días
no tengo tatuajes en la piel pero si en
el corazón es ahí ese momento cuando
gritas un gol cuando ves correr al
hombre más rápido del mundo o
simplemente entonar tu himno nacional
hasta quedarte sin vos somos lo que
contamos somos lo que vivimos por eso
siempre sueña sueña tantas veces que la
misión por que estamos aquí se cumpla
sueña porque si eso te hace feliz seguro
eso transmitidas por el resto de tu vida
hoy sigue un paso adelante y a pesar de
haber cumplido algunos de mis sueños esa
historia siempre debe continuar
nunca permitamos que nada ni nadie nos
corte las alas porque esas alas siempre
nos harán volar ahora seamos más rápidos
brinquemos más almas seamos más fuertes
y metamos el mejor gol de nuestras vidas
les comentaba que la herencia que me
deja mi padre son esas dos y el deporte
para mí ha sido parte fundamental de mi
vida porque me hace degenerado
disciplina a través de disciplina llevo
23 años en la radio trabajando en uno de
los programas más exitosos de la ciudad
y generando historias e ideas para todos
nuestros clientes
cuando yo entro a la radio
y tengo la oportunidad de poder generar
un concierto que se llamaba el concierto
exa el concierto exa era un evento que
se realizaba aquí en la ciudad donde
participaban alrededor de 14 artistas en
un solo escenario imagínense traer a 14
artistas de diferentes estados de la
república o inclusive en diferentes
países para poder traerlos al escenario
del cosep ortiz de domínguez y meter a
14 artistas hay era algo que era
increíble aquí en querétaro no se ha
visto hicimos 14 conciertos y cada
concierto para mí era todo un reto
siempre tenía que ser más y más y más y
el escenario tenía que estar increíble y
tenía que ver más tecnología obviamente
no existían las redes sociales en aquel
entonces y por eso de repente las redes
sociales generaron que fueran
alcanzables los artistas y ya no era tan
atractivo para la gente ir a un
concierto exa ya me costaba mucho más
trabajo lograr que fueran y que
asistieran y que se ganaran los boletos
etcétera generaba dinero para la empresa
sí pero no es suficiente como para poder
generar lo que se me se había perdido
por ser vacaciones o por lo que la radio
en ese momento dejaba
14 conciertos imagínense nunca pensé en
ningún concierto que me iba a pasar
nunca pensé que se iba a caer a alguien
nunca pensé que no iba a funcionar un
micrófono nunca pensé que voy a pasar
algo que pudiera estropear todo el
trabajo que hicimos durante 3 meses 34
meses involucramos a toda la empresa
para que pudiera este concierto será una
realidad
después de que pasa esto el concierto
exa
deja de ser redituable para todos los
que asisten y yo tenía que generar un
proyecto que genera dinero para la
empresa pero que también pudiera ir de
la mano con mis sueños y esta herencia
que me deja mi padre por el deporte y
por el fútbol recuerdo mucho a mi abuelo
sentado en su sofá recuerdo mucho a mi
papá también viendo los partidos de
fútbol el fin de semana pero el tenis
para mí fue lo como lo más importante
sin embargo él en la sangre aéreo el
fútbol y me apasionaba muchísimo yo
tenía que generar un proyecto para la
empresa que le diera más dinero que el
concierto exa sin artistas y sin gastar
tanto dinero se gastaba mucho y se gana
tiene un impacto en la sociedad tiene un
impacto de la ciudad muy importante pero
pues ya no genera dinero y ya en lugar
de que viniera aleks syntek v7 ya venían
los youtubers o artistas que habían
salido en las redes sociales y eso ya no
era tan atractivo
mi primer sueño cumplido es el que les
quiero contar a continuación y es que
fue el llegar con mi jefe y platicar
requerido mundial y me dijo el que no
iba a pagar el dinero no iba a dar el
dinero para irme al mundial que era lo
que yo quería y no era generar un
proyecto un producto que supiera el
concierto exa y que generará mucho más
dinero que el concierto anterior que fue
el último que lo hicimos aquí en el
parque bicentenario y asistieron 14.000
personas ha sido el concierto más grande
en ese parque
y dije que quería yo ir al mundial y
genere un proyecto que se llamaba el
rincón del mundial yo me llamo david
rincón así me ha pedido y
logré convencer a mi jefe para que él me
ayudara a poder materializar este sueño
me puso un reto de una venta que tenía
que duplicar la venta que hacía el
concierto exa me moví fui con los
vendedores fuimos con todo el mundo a
poder venderles este sueño que yo tenía
y se logró y fuimos a brasil a cubrir en
mi primer sueño que fue el río muerto en
brasil-2014
esa foto que ustedes ven del lado
izquierdo en ese momento ahí fue cuando
yo me dije
que había cumplido ese sueño y que lo
que había soñado lo había logrado sin
embargo fue el primer partido de mexico
y fue el primer momento en que transmití
algo desde un estadio me topé con faltas
de tecnología me topé con falta de
dinero porque no hice el presupuesto
adecuado me topé con muchas trabas me
acuerdo perfecto en brasil-2014 la
tecnología no estaba como ahora
que yo para poder encontrar internet
tenía que pagar en un restaurant caro
porque en los baratos no había internet
gratuito tienes que pagarlo entonces yo
me administraba el dinero poco a poco el
primer día que yo llegaba a la sede
buscaba un restaurante que tuviera wifi
y todas mis transmisiones al día
siguiente tardaba 44 días más o menos
por ciudad cuatro días hacía mis
transmisiones afuera del restaurante con
wifi gratis
son cosas que vas aprendiendo durante la
marcha yo hubiera pedido más dinero para
el presupuesto para comprar internet
pero no lo hice así le falle en los
números aprendí y conocí lugares
maravillosos tomé 9 aviones en dentro de
brasil a veces había 5 horas de vuelo
para poder viajar de una ciudad a otra
pero aprendí muchísimo después de esto
viene mi segundo sueño cumplido
dicen que los sueños cumplir que los
sueños se comparten yo tengo un programa
con dos amigos míos que llevamos 19 años
al aire y lo que yo viví en brasil lo
tenía que compartir con ellos ellos no
tener que vivir con ellos
pudimos lograr que el proyecto de los
juegos olímpicos se materializará de la
igual manera que de brasil pero mi jefe
me subió un poquito más la meta y schumi
y pudimos vender ese mismo dinero y
logramos vender un poco más de lo que la
meta a mí me habían puesto
estas fotografías que ustedes ven
también son partes súper importantes en
esa ocasión yo no iba de la mejor manera
me podría llamar que en ese momento
tenía problemas personales estaba roto
completamente roto sin embargo tuve que
cumplir el proyecto y me acuerdo muy
poco de rio-2016 me acuerdo muy poco
por la situación en la que yo estaba
pasando en ese momento sin embargo
logramos rentar un departamento y poner
una cabina de radio en el río de janeiro
y transmitimos algo que ninguna estación
de radio en querétaro había logrado ni
tampoco un mundial nunca había habido
una transmisión local siempre
visualizábamos que las transmisiones de
los mundiales o de los juegos olímpicos
son para las empresas gigantes como
televisa o como tv azteca que eran los
que cubrían esos eventos porque no una
estación local con un presupuesto local
con patrocinadores locales pueden estar
en un escenario como ese obviamente con
las plataformas y con las limitaciones y
con la tecnología como una empresa
pequeña pero podemos estar ahí y
estuvimos ahí y pudimos ver al hombre
más rápido del mundo y pudimos ver a
michael phelps y podemos ver a los
tenistas y pudimos ver a méxico en los
clavados y pudimos ver cosas
maravillosas y pudimos descubrir que
como méjico o como los mexicanos no hay
dos somos únicos jaime me sugirieron que
cuando fuera de estos eventos pusieran
mi playera la bandera de méxico no saben
la manera en que tratan a los mexicanos
en otros lugares
nos aman nos quieren muchísimo y eso a
veces no le damos el valor aqui en
mexico pero los mexicanos quieren mucho
fuimos a los olímpicos logré ver la
medalla de oro de golf vi cosas
increíbles pero a la luz se me quedó muy
grabado en rio de janeiro
en la competencia de usain bolt para
verlo correr me tardé tres horas en
llegar me tardé tres horas en entrar y
lo vi diez segundos
y fueron los 10 segundos más
maravillosos de mi vida porque puedo
entender muchas cosas puede entender que
hay que prepararse para poder lograr sus
sueños
como una persona una sola persona puede
hacer tanto tanto tanto o generar tanto
las personas en 10 segundos antes de que
compitiera usain bolt había una mujer de
color que estuvo corriendo los 1500
metros se le cayó el zapato a la mitad
la competencia lleva viva en primer
lugar y de repente ella se detiene a
ponerse el zapato pero por la adrenalina
del evento no logra ponerse los zapatos
se los quita y empieza a correr porque
ya le habían rebasado esta mujer ganó la
competencia ese día
ese día lo tengo muy presente porque al
final del día fue
esa imagen que yo tengo de representar
esa imagen que me representa en ese
momento de los juegos olímpicos' ahí fue
cuando dije tienes que lograr tus sueños
siempre no te puedes parar aunque te
salgan los zapatos aprendí muchas cosas
en río aprendimos también temas de
tecnología en fin seguía otro sueño y
venía a rusia y porque no estaba en
rusia si había gustado en brasilia
gustado en río pues logramos ir a rusia
con un proyecto mucho más ambicioso la
tecnología estaba mucho más avanzada en
esta ocasión fui con el de deportes y
viví otro momento histórico méxico le
ganó a alemania en el estadio luzhnikí
increíble de los pronósticos no eran
esos la tecnología me permitió poder
transmitir en ese momento esa emoción
que yo tenía y la gente de querétaro me
escribía sea ya sea hacia rusia es
increíble porque el momento que tú estás
narrando todo lo que estás diciendo yo
me siento ahí contigo
y se los cuento así con esta pasión
porque lo que hago me apasiona porque
amo lo que hago porque lo respeto porque
lo cuido porque lo protege a mí no a
nadie nadie me va a quitar esto que yo
he trabajado durante tantos años
rusia fue para mí la consolidación de
muchas cosas a diferencia del río
aquí ya viva completo y pleno y me
acuerdo hasta el olor de las cosas me
acuerdo de las sensaciones que me
generaban estadio el ver en la mañana
levantarme porque tenía que llegar cinco
horas antes al estadio y ver la playera
de méxico con mi apellido en la espalda
y decía logré otro sueño
siempre tengo un sueño adelante siempre
siempre voy por por otro más la pandemia
nos trajo
a todos una descomposición y una
no nos afectó mucho en nuestro día a día
tokio era el proyecto anterior y no lo
pudimos materializar por el tema de la
pandemia no nos dejaron ir
el gobierno japonés no permitió que los
medios de comunicación
locales que no tuvieran acreditaciones
que no tuvieran derechos de transmisión
pudieran estar ahí sin embargo el sueño
tiene que continuar y venía también
qatar que es el siguiente el siguiente
mundial para catar
nosotros hemos preparado ya un proyecto
desde ahorita hemos separado un proyecto
2.0 donde vamos a ir de nuevo todos mis
compañeros a transmitir el mundial vamos
mucho más equipados vamos con más ideas
para redes sociales que ahora tienen que
estar
pegadas al proyecto sin embargo nos
duplicaron todavía
el dinero que debemos de ganar de los
dos proyectos o de este aspectos
anteriores en pandemia y nosotros ya lo
estamos vendiendo desde ahorita a pesar
de que falta mucho tiempo a lo que voy
es que
estas imágenes que les mostré al final
del día me traen la mayor alegría de mi
vida independientemente de mi familia de
mis hijos de que todo se puede cumplir
de que no hay límites a pesar de que
vivamos en una ciudad pequeña a pesar de
que estemos una estación de radio local
las ideas y los sueños son inalcanzables
hace algún tiempo
mi padre falleció cuando yo tenía
alrededor de 30 años y tener un amigo
muy querido
que le costaba mucho trabajo comunicarse
conmigo de manera personal él tiene un
problema de drogas muy fuerte
y él lo encontró en un correo
electrónico a la manera de poderse
expresar el dolor que sentía conmigo de
la muerte de mi padre
y en el momento que yo leí ese correo me
hizo mucho clic y tiene que ver mucho
con las imágenes que les acabo de
mostrar ese correo decía que lo conservo
todavía con ese correo decía que cuando
yo estuviera viviendo un momento bonito
de mi vida
me imaginaba
que mi padre lo estaba pintando mi padre
aparte de ser deportista era pintor y en
cada momento en cada espacio que vivo y
feliz que la paso bien que lo comparto
con gente como ustedes me imagino que mi
papá lo pinto
y hoy este momento también los pintores
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]